welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for a presentation
titled image and data processing for hcs
toxicology it's my pleasure to introduce
you to dr david egan
david is a ceo and co-founder of the
core
life analytics and joining david today
is liz
rivitsky and liz is a senior scientist
in
genetic toxicology at fitzer for
complete biography of our speakers
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
now if any questions arise during the
presentation we want to encourage you to
submit them
in the q a box our speaker will address
your questions
following the end of the presentation
please join me
now to in welcoming david and
liz i will now turn the presentation
over to them
welcome to both of you
hello there uh i'm dave reegan and it's
a pleasure to be able to talk to you
today about
how high content screening technologies
are used
for toxicology now
to get started what i'd like to do is
just to give you you know a brief
overview of the history of how we've
ended up where we are today
so one of the things that's very
important to know
is that in the 80s and 90s there was a
large push towards the industrialization
of
drug discovery and so there were a
number of enabling
technologies that came together to allow
for this
one was the availability of modern
molecular biology and biochemistry
techniques also and genome
gene sequencing and this allowed people
to
really get you know do a lot more
advanced studies on disease processes
and allowed for the identification of
new drug targets
it also allowed for the development of
very specific assays biochemical assays
for these drug targets this when
combined with
laboratory automation and combat or
chemistry that allowed for the
generation of large numbers of
different you know chemical structures
allowed
the development of what was became known
as targeted drug discovery
where a pharmaceutical companies would
be able to generate large libraries of
thousands or even millions of compounds
that they could then test against very
specific targeted assays
in high throughput and ultra high
throughput screens
and the whole idea was that if we could
test more targets we would get more
leads
and then we'd be able to generate more
drugs at this stage
safety and toxicology was generally
tested here in the pre-clinical
development stage
so if you look at this kind of drug to
discovery pipeline from the early stage
discovery through to
the the different clinical trials here
just before the clinical trials was
where safety was taken was
actually studied and compounds were
tested for safety
generally this was done in animal
studies now there was a problem with
this that became apparent
whole process became apparent in over
the course of the autism there was
actually
almost a small cottage industry
developed in
publishing papers about this problem is
that
the whole process did not give the
expected return on investment
the number of compounds that were
actually going to market
did not increase in comparison to the
number of programs that were being
generated and the number of compounds
that were going into
clinical trials one of the the major
problems that people discovered was that
a lot of the compounds that were going
into clinical trials were failing
there were a number of reasons for this
efficacy toxicity in animals
but unfortunately also adverse reactions
in humans
in compounds that were getting through
to the market also
pharmac pharmacokinetics the
bioavailability of of compounds
uh some problems with that as as i
mentioned there were
some very high profile market
withdrawals where compounds actually
went through
these trials and then you got problems
in humans
and what was found that in the 25 years
to 1999
about 0.7 approved drugs were withdrawn
per year
but in 1994-2006 this actually went
up to 2.1 approved drugs withdrawn from
the market per year
and 80 of these withdrawals were due to
hepatotoxicity liver toxicity or
cardiotoxicity so if we look at this
figure here this
shows what was the the scale of the
problem
apart from infectious diseases where you
had reasonable success rates
for these other types of drugs in
cardiovascular disease cancer or cns
disorders you had very low success rates
in phase one and phase two
and slightly higher rates in in phase
three so this is a serious problem
and when you looked at the reasons for
compounds failing
yeah toxicity in animals and adver
adverse reactions
in humans had a substantial
were substantial reasons for uh for the
failure
one of the major problems is that as i
said
the compounds at this point were
generally being tested in
animal studies here at this point for
toxicity
but especially with hepatotoxicity it
turned out that only 50 percent of
hepatic toxic drugs
were would have been detected in animals
so
it turns out that animal species do not
predict
human metabolism of drugs very well
and animal species do not predict the
diversity of human patients
also normal healthy animals are not
predictive of the effects of drugs and
the problems of drugs in diseased human
patients
and it seemed that when it came to
hepatotoxicity especially there was a
subpopulation of human patients
who are particularly sensitive to
adverse drug reactions
other problems with animal studies
they're extremely expensive also
uh over the course of the the the 90s
and the audi's
there became a lot of popular opposition
to animal studies so
pharmaceutical companies really came
under pressure to reduce the number of
animals they were using
also from a practical standpoint animal
studies just can't
support the higher throughput of
compounds that was coming through
through the pipelines what was decided
is that what we
needed in the industry was
to identify talk to toxic compounds
earlier in the drug discovery pathway
and the idea was that we really needed
predictive assays that would would allow
people to predict whether compounds
would be toxic or and that then
these problems could be engineered out
with
medicinal chemistry or the compounds
could be just rejected a kind of a fail
early approach
and so what this required was in vitro
assays these predictive individuals that
could be deployed
in a high throughput fashion early on in
the drug discovery because here you're
talking about larger numbers of
chemicals to be screened
not just a handful of chemicals that you
might be putting into animal studies
uh further down the pipeline now
fortunately there was a successful
precedent
for this type of strategy in
pharmacokinetics
and one of the major problems that had
been discovered is that the compounds
especially oral compounds
were failing due to a lack of
bioavailability
they were not being absorbed in the gut
and so what was developed was an in
vitro
assay in order to test whether compounds
would be absorbed and this is called the
kco2
assay and basically these caico2 cells
which were a i believe a
colon carcinoma cell line could be
plated on a membrane in
this little transwell insert here and
they would form tight junctions so form
a tight barrier so the only way drugs
could get from this compartment to this
compartment
would be by actually passaging passing
through the cells
and this was found to mimic
bioavailability via gut endothelial
quite well and you can see here
how for a lot of these compounds that it
was very
uh highly predictive of their ability to
be absorbed
in the gut compounds that do have
problems with this assay are ones that
are subject to
active transport and so they could not
be predicted because
they're highly fluxed by by drug pumps
in the uh in the gut so before we
go uh go ahead i want to talk about some
terminology
and define some terms that that you'll
see coming up in some of the examples
that i'll show you later on
and these are about assay sensitivity
specificity other ways of
of defining the quality of your assay
so assay sensitivity is how well an
assay
identifies in our case toxic compounds
so it's the total number of compounds
detected as being toxic over the total
number of toxic compounds that are in
our test set
now specificity is uh
how accurately it detects
toxic compounds so here this means
essentially the number of toxic
compounds detected
divided by the total compounds detected
and so
you could have an acid that's very
sensitive it's very uh
it's very good at detecting toxic
compounds but it may not be specific
in that a lot of the things that it's
detecting may be
false positives obviously what you want
is an assay that's both sensitive
and specific and there are other values
that are used such as the positive
predictive value
and so this is how well an essay
identifies positives the negative
predictive value how well
an essay identifies negatives another
important and useful one is the balanced
accuracy
if you have the accuracy for detecting
let's say
toxic compounds or non-toxic compounds
to get an overall
view of the assay you could take
those accuracies for each of those
classes and then get the mean of that
and that gives you uh an idea of how
good your assay is at
detecting both so with that in mind we
can move along
and what we can talk about is the actual
in vitro assays that were available to
people who wanted to do this earlier
detection of toxic compounds
these types of assays that were
available at the time
were mostly based on very late stage
toxic events
cell count apoptosis or
some sort of events that may not pos
may not possibly be linked to actual
toxicity so
uh one way of measuring cell viability
is to measure atp levels
but these can go up or go down in ways
that do not actually
affect cell viability similarly various
measures for
cell metabolism the problem with these
uh
assays that were already there were that
they had you know low
sensitivity there are many false
positives but they did have
very many false negatives but they did
have high specificity
and that they detected few few uh false
positives
and so you can see here some of these
assays outlined in this table
and you can see how the various
sensitivities here
were quite low the highest would be
around 19
but the specificities were quite good so
things that you were detecting
then yes they were definitely toxic um
so the up
upshot of this was that these assays
were good for detecting highly toxic
compounds
but not really good for predicting
compounds
that were toxic due to let's say chronic
exposure things like that
and certainly not good for detecting
what are known as idiopathic
compounds so compounds that only affect
a small number of people that's not
really understood why
the proposed solution then to replace
these assays to come up with more
predictive assays
was to focus on earlier events
in uh in the toxic kind of process and
events that were more linked to the type
of toxicity that you were looking at
so for example for hepatotoxicity you'd
focus on things that are important
in uh in liver cells for example it was
known from
the understanding of hepatotoxicity that
steatosis was a problem this is the
accumulation of fatty acids also
cholestasis the impairment of bile
formation the accumulation of
phospholipids
it was known that reactive metabolites
could cause problems
and these could be measured another
very important factor in hepatocyte
biology is you know the mitochondrial
function the various functions of
hepatocytes require a lot of energy so
anything that disrupted mitochondrial
membrane potential
would be a problem and so this could be
measured also oxidative stress the
metabolism causes a lot of
oxidative stress and so the measurement
of damaging free radicals
was useful another uh type
of assay that was used were
p450 assays the cytochrome p450s are
very important for the metabolism
of drugs in the liver and compounds that
would inhibit
these could cause problems with let's
say drug drug interactions
so if someone was taking two drugs one
drug inhibits a p450 that's metabolizing
the other
then the concentration of the other drug
could become very high and cause
problems
and so these were also
adopted fortunately for a lot of
these uh types of assays
there were various fluorescent markers
out there that could be used
with uh cellular systems uh a bunch of
them are outlined here in
this table so by all just had some
flexibility in how to build these assays
as regards the cell types that were
available
initially a lot of the work was done in
hep g2 cells which were
a hepatocellular carcinoma cells
that seemed to be pretty good at
mimicking
some certain liver functions
people subsequently adopted cell systems
that were more physiologically relevant
for example primary hepatocytes
from from humans and animals also more
recently
ips derives hepatocytes
also 3d systems so sort of
mini livers essentially in various
different
3d systems and the combination of these
cell systems and the various fluorescent
markers available
meant that people could adopt high
content analysis
for these assays now i'll give a very
brief description of high content
analysis
because there will be more in-depth
discussions of the overall technology
available in some of the talks that are
coming up subsequently
we'll talk about those later on but
basically high content analysis
is where you set up a cell-based assay
in a multi-world plate
and then instead of taking a simple
readout with a plate reader
you actually use an automated microscope
to image the cells in the well
so that in combination with uh various
fluorescent markers
then can give you a very a very useful
opportunity
where you can do image analysis and you
can use automated image analysis to
extract
numeric descriptors of the various
labeled organelles or the cells
themselves
and so what this gives you then is a
very rich essentially morphological
profile of what's going on in a well
high content analysis had a number of
things to offer
when combined with toxicology assays
one is that you could use it for
monitoring live cells easily
single cell monitoring was possible also
you can
do simultaneous multi-parametric
monitoring
so you'll see later on how this offers a
flux of opportunities for
the use of things like machine learning
also it allows
for iterative measurements over the same
well or even the same cell
and so you can follow things in time the
different types of assays that were
could be
combined in these systems uh
were diverse in that you could have
biochemical assays various
immunochemical assays as well as
morphological measurements of the cells
themselves
the assay is also very amenable to
automation use using robotics so you
could actually get
high throughput that was required in
earlier stages in drug discovery
another thing you do especially compared
to animal studies is
lower costs it can be more reproducible
and it's also can be combined with more
complex cellular systems
ips cell lines 3d cell lines and co
cultures so the reason
i started with hepatotoxicity
is that that's probably where the the
most progress has been made
in cytotox assays for using high content
screening technologies and i want to
show you a few examples now of various
different platforms that have been
developed
and the first one is an assay that was
developed
back in the mid 2000s by
peter o'brien and a group from pfizer at
the old
sandwich pfizer site in the uk and
this was a high content uh
platform but was you know based on
four uh different dies and so
tmrm for mitochondrial membrane
potential fluorophore for intracellular
calcium
uh that increases in in in cells that
are
stressed and then host for nuclear and
cell number and total 3 for cytoplasmic
membrane permeability so you can see
that here on the left you can see these
are cells
that have been treated in a control and
then here cells
where you're getting been treated with a
hepatotoxic compound
now the cell line that they decided to
use here were hep g2s which was a human
hepatocarcinoma cell and so this has
some
metabolic activities that you know make
it
suitable for these type of type of work
so the way they set up the experiment
was
to treat the cells with compounds in 12
doses
and the idea was to get to 100 times the
the c-max this is the maximum
concentration of a drug
that you would initially see in a an
animal or a human
if that wasn't possible try and get to
100 micromolar
as positive controls they used tween uh
for nuclear size and cell permeability
ionomycin fccp which
collapses mitochondrial potential now
one key thing
is they found that preoccupation with
the drugs
was essential and so incubation of the
drugs for three days
uh uh seemed to be uh required and then
the idea was after
pre-incubation with the drugs add dyes
and then image over the course of around
three hours taking images every
half hour or so in the four different
channels
the way they would call drugs or
compounds as being cytotoxic
was to plot dose response curves for
the four different uh measurements and
then
any drug that gave a greater than two
times the standard deviation
uh from the mean negative control
within that dose was then called
called as a toxic toxic drug
here's an example of uh the data
from a myoderon
uh in this platform and so what you can
see here
these are at each concentration you can
see
the the the time course of the imaging
over the course of uh three hours and
for the various different labels and
then what's very obvious here
is then you can see here with these
doses everything looks pretty much the
same
and then around this dose here for the
mitochondrial membrane potential
things start to go awry
then here you can see with the the
calcium it starts to increase here
around this concentration
with host you see start to start see
changes around here
uh in nuclear area
and then here with the total for cell
permeability
then around here you start to see
increases cell permeability so you can
see
that the different measurements you
start to get responses
at uh at different concentrations so
if we were to look at this it would
probably be calcium would be
the the earliest uh the one that's
getting uh where you're seeing an effect
at the the lowest concentration here
what was very encouraging when this was
analyzed is they looked at a panel of
611 compounds with
conventional in vitro assays and as we
uh
discussed previously the specificity of
these types of assays was very high but
the sensitivity
was very low so you were not picking up
all
the hepatotoxic compounds but the ones
you were picking up were very likely to
be correct
with this high content assay however in
a test with 243 compounds
both sensitivity and the specificity
were
high sensitivity of 93 percent and it's
best
specificity of 98 so this was extremely
encouraging
the idea that you could run this assay
at an early uh
early stage in the drug discovery
process
and then be able to um accurately call
and predict compounds that would uh
could potentially cause problems later
on
so there were a couple of things that
the uh that this
um setting up this essay highlighted one
was that for certain drugs
pre-incubation with the compound
was essential for certain drugs here in
the left it wasn't required
uh you could get effects even without
pre-incubation to compound
but with these ones on the right it was
really was necessary
to get a incubation uh pre-incubation
for up to three days so they arrived at
kind of a standard set of conditions
where you would do pre-incubation for
three days
another thing that was highlighted was
that
single cell analysis
was very useful especially for
looking at let's say the sequence of
events that were happening
the different kind of things that were
being triggered by individual
drugs and so high content analysis of
course is very good for this in that you
can follow
single cells using the high content
analysis
another thing that was highlighted was
an effect known as hormesis and hormesis
is where you get an initial increase in
uh a value with dose but then it starts
to go back down again
and so if you were to try and plot those
response curves with
the normal models for these kind of
responses
you're not going to get a curve and so a
normal curve would look like this
and that works fine with the standard
methods but with these types of curves
you have to come up with
a better model in order to fit curves
for these and these are
these are consistent responses you see
these
reproducibly and so they actually used a
different model in order to take
take account of these types of responses
and so this this sort of things were
very important so when we look at the
various different
measurements that were being used of the
four different measurements the
highest sensitivity one was cell count
and then nuclear area
and then calcium the least sensitive
parameter seemed to be the mitochondrial
membrane potential the next example
is a more recent paper from litzin lou
and danielle
zink at the a-star in singapore and
this is also a hepatotoxicity assay
and there the problem they were looking
at is
that um at this point the gold standard
cell system for hepatotoxicity are
primary human hepatocytes
uh from uh a sourced postmortem
um obviously yeah these are expensive
and and
uh and can be difficult to get and of
course yet there may be some issues with
with reproducibility but what's also
another problem with these is that you
can get de-differentiation
of these uh primary hepatocytes
and then you get a loss of metabolic
acid activity
um so this group were looking for a more
reproducible system
where you did have as much of this
the metabolic activity possible and so
one cell and they were looking at were
hepar
hepa org cells which were probably
they thought of as being more liver-like
than hep g2 cells and they had more of
the
the metabolic activity but where you
didn't get this de-differentiation
effect uh they also looked at different
markers
uh dapi for dna which course is common
with the last
uh example but then they also looked at
rel a relay is a sub unit of nf kappa b
with the transcription factor which gets
translocated
into the nucleus in in response to
stress
and if this of course is quite a
dramatic phenotype in a high content
assay
and so they use this the marker and also
uh f actin looked at f actin so which is
of course
a good indicator of changes in uh in
cell shape
and in the the cytoskeleton and so the
what they first did was
just to look at these hepa or orgisa
lines they just use standard
cytotoxic toxic measurements and exon 5
for looking
at apoptosis and
ethidium homodiometer 3 for looking at
permeability cell permeability
and then looked at a panel of cytotoxic
cell of
hepatotoxic compounds and uh
you know non-toxic compounds to see if
they could
measure these with
with this system and this looks
promising and so then they moved on to
constructing
their their high content assay with the
other
markers and so here again they could
get responses with known toxic compounds
and the idea was to you know generate
this as a robust assay
again pre-treat the cells for 16 hours
but then to fix them instead of doing
life
cell analysis they could fix the cells
and then
image them and this use of fixed cells
actually makes things uh in practical
terms easier to run in high throughput
as opposed to a live lifestyle approach
so this is something that actually makes
an assay more practical to run in in
with larger numbers of compounds now
one thing that was different between
this approach
and the uh the previous platform that we
looked at
is that they didn't just take the
obvious
uh a number of obvious measurements they
actually made use
of more of the power of high content
analysis
now one thing about these high content
screening instruments and the image
analysis software that you can
you can use with them is that you can
actually pull out a lot
of different measurements potentially
hundreds or even a couple of thousand
measurements depending on the
image analysis platform that you use
instead of taking one measurement for
each of our labels
what this group is they calculated you
know
all many different measurements and then
they use this in this clustering
clustering uh method here using
hierarchical clustering
to cluster the responses of all the
chemicals in the library
so with the hepatotoxic compounds in
red and the non-toxic compounds in blue
and then clustered all of these
responses against
all of the different features okay and
so what you can see
is that you get clustering here of a lot
of the hepatotoxic compounds
over in this area over here and what you
can also see
is that there are two features here that
are rel a features you can see them
labeled in here they're from the relay
channel
that are extremely high in signaling
for you know toxic compounds here you
can see these are these kind of
purple boxes here that line up with the
red guys and you don't see them over
here with the
with the negatives so what they decided
to do next was
to actually take this now that this kind
of gave some confidence
that this overall platform could
separate
the toxic from non-toxic compounds but
they wanted to optimize this
and the way that they did this was
actually to use a machine learning
approach
the machine learning the method the
method they used was support vector
machine
and i'm not going to going to go into
all the details about machine learning
but basically machine learning is what's
called a supervised method
where you take classes of known
toxic and non-toxic compounds
and then you train a model over that and
then that model can then be used
to apply to other data sets and you get
essentially a measurement of whether
those
other wells are giving responses that
are similar to toxic
or to non-toxic one of the kind of
byproducts
of the support uh the vector machine
learning model like all these
a lot of these machine learning models
is that it it outputs a rank order of
all of the features or measurements
according to how important they
are for your model in order to
distinguish between your different
classes
and so here what they found was that in
the sport vector machine one of these
the most one of these
rel a features that came up in the
clustering was the most important
feature
distinguishing between between toxic and
non-toxic
and here you can see if we use that
for calling hits and for plotting dose
response curves
you can see here that the using this
as an assay gives a a very
specific assay but it's not
not quite sensitive enough by that if
you go back to our definitions again
it's very specific in that all of the
compounds over here that it's calling as
toxic compounds are indeed toxic toxic
compounds
but it's not very sensitive in that you
can see that it's actually missing
quite a few uh compounds over here here
with the negatives
you can see that nearly everything is
called negative it is picking up a few
negative compounds as being as being
positive and so if you look here at the
numbers
for sensitivity and specificity you're
getting
a sensitivity of a little over 50
percent
but the specificity is quite high so
you're not picking up all the toxic
compounds but the ones that you are
picking up
are more highly likely to be actually
toxic
okay and then here's our balanced
accuracy it's out here
uh a little over 70
this top feature and the idea of taking
a single feature
and uh and using it for our calling
yes it could be useful but you know
there was a possibility to come up with
something
better and one thing you can do to come
up with a better model is actually to
come up with
a smaller set of features that
do contribute together to give you a
more robust asset
and so this is what they did if we look
at again if we look at this single
feature here it gives these
sensitivities and specificities and
balance accuracies but what they did was
they went back
and used what's known as recursive
feature elimination
with support vector machine in order to
come up with a better set of
measurements
that would allow a better assay and so
the way you do this
is that you build and test a support
vector machine model
and then you start eliminating the least
important important features in
iterative manner
and then build and test your model again
until you come up with a model
that actually gives the the the best the
best performance
and so in this case they narrowed it
down to a
30 feature set that could be used in
support vector machine
that actually gave very high sensitivity
this time
very high specificity and a better
balance accuracy
and so this is a nice example of how you
can really make use of the
full power of high content analysis
you're calculating many features
some of which you may not really
understand
what their connection is with with your
biology but by using machine learning
you can
use you can combine these features and
come up with a feature set that actually
gives you
a very sensitive specific and and
accurate uh
model okay we're back to nephrotoxicity
again
with this platform that was generated by
uh
joachim gehrig at the university of
heidelberg in germany
in when you're looking at assays there's
always
especially high throughput assays
there's always a trade-off between
the practicality and the suitability for
high throughput applications
and physiological relevance as we
discussed earlier
using whole animals and mammals mice
whatever is you know not practical for
very high throughput applications
but as you get down to using more
reductionist systems
individual cell lines in single cultures
then you start to lose the complexity of
being in the whole
animal and because of that there may be
things that you miss
fortunately there are other animal
models that are amenable to high
throughput
and screening and one of those is
zebrafish
zebrafish have a fairly simple embryo
and and that can be labeled with gfp and
because zebrafish embryos are
transparent
you can then easily image them in this
in this uh assay i think and i think
this is one the
is probably the coolest thing i'll show
you today what you can do is you can
isolate synchronized
zebrafish embryos and plate them in
these
uh 12 well plates in these 12-volt
plates they could they can be treated
with
candidate compounds that you're testing
for nephrotoxicity
and then what you do is you remove the
corion and what you do then
is you put them in a 96 well plate but
in this case there's a gross on the
bottom with a channel in it
and then the zebrafish each zebrafish
embryo can fit into
into a channel and now the zebrafish
embryo is in
they're all in the same orientation once
you have them in the 96 well plate
then it's pretty straightforward to
image them and with some
cool image analysis methods you can
actually
crop the image to get down to just an
image of
the zebrafish kidney itself
and here's example of a 96 well plate
of zebrafish kidneys and in row f down
here you can see
that there are is a toxic compound a
nephrotoxic compound and it's easy to
see even by the naked eye
that these kidneys are something is not
quite right
after this you have to move on to
extract some sort of
numeric features from these images now
in this case
it's not so easy you need some sort of
manual intervention
and in this study the this group used
two different methods
now the first one was where they took a
where a scientist went in
and labeled these critical points
in each of the kidney images then
software
could easily calculate these distances
and angles
okay to come up with six different
features
that could then be used for for output
from the assay also there were kind of
non-renal features that could be
extracted that described various other
aspects of the whole
embryo so this was one method that they
used
another method was to build a system
where
an expert could quickly look at each of
the kidneys and score them according to
uh to various metrics so what they did
then is
they took these different methods
and they compared them and so you can
see it in clustering where they compared
the quantitative method
where the software generated numbers and
the qualitative method where the expert
generated the scores for each of the uh
each of the kidneys and they actually
came up and agreed
very well so for the here you can see
the various different nephrotoxic
compounds that were detected in the in
both
experiments now that you have all of
these
individual scores what you can also do
is you can take those and those are now
a a profile that you can use to classify
different toxic compounds here we see an
example
of a uh negative compound and then in
red
some positive compounds and you what you
can see is that
some of the different compounds have
quite different
uh profiles and so this one here for
example has a very different profile
from this one but this one is kind of
similar to this one
maybe more similar to this one and so
this kind of
shows you that you can probably get some
some sort of
insight into mechanism of action from
the shape of these
the shape of these profiles
so what the group did then is they
actually took all of these
these metrics and carried out principal
component analysis
and then this is of course a data
reduction method that we'll talk about
more later
but then what you can do is once you've
reduced it down to three principal
components
what you can do is you can plot the
various different points
in three-dimensional space and here what
you can see is that
these different compounds here is
uh ketoprofen and out here is
is fenbufin and you can see that they're
in different areas in three-dimensional
space
and this is indicative of the different
kind of mechanism of action
so if you remember back to that dna
relay f-actin assay we saw that you
could use the same assay
for toxicity in hepatocytes
or toxicity in kidney cells
and even though it's the same assay we
could see that different features were
actually most important
for the different types of toxicity so
this is kind of interesting how you
could use one kind of assay for
different types of biology
so that kind of leads to the idea of
okay well what if you had
an even broader assay that could be you
know
more even more broadly useful that could
maybe even be
completely independent of
different types of toxicities or
different types of targets
and actually there is something like
this and it's called cell painting
and if you've already been involved at
all in high content analysis there's a
very good chance you've already
heard about this so the idea behind cell
painting
is exactly that a very rich assay with a
lot of different
labels that can be used to profile all
sorts of bioactive molecules
so here's the idea is that you can
label cells with five different uh
dyes and so this is a very simple assay
to
run and that they're all chemical dyes
and
very useful for automation and life cell
imaging
and the dyes are for host for the
nucleus and then
the endoplasmic label the endoplasmic
reticulum the nuclei
ola and cytoplasmic rna actin golgi in
the plasma membrane and mitochondria so
here are the various dyes that are used
in the classic cell painting protocol
and the idea is is that you can then set
up this assay and use it to test
various different chemicals or genetic
perturbations
again go through the standard high
content analysis pipeline
with automated imaging and then
automated image analysis
except this time because you have so
many different labels and
the group ran it through a uh an image
it was developed by the carpenter lab at
the uh the broad institute
they ran it through cell profiler which
is an open source
image analysis platform that that group
had also developed
and this generates a lot of different
features lots of different texture
features for all the different
channels as well as the usual
intensities and things like this
and so then you end up with maybe one
and a half thousand
different features that give you a very
rich data set
from which to which to work with and to
generate profiles
obviously this could be you know very
useful also
for profiling you know toxic uh
toxic molecules and so this is exactly
what josh harrell at the epa
who's published a couple of different
papers on the use of cell painting for
toxicology now
and he has a quote about this in a reach
a recent nature webcast which
i i would definitely recommend that you
check out and
the idea is that you know to use cell
painting as a very broad
kind of assay which could capture all
sorts of different uh
molecular and phenotypic responses and
of course their interest
is to identify compounds that could be
toxic in the environment what josh and
his group did was they actually
used cell painting in order to
see if they can identify environmentally
problematic compounds so they actually
set up two different assays
the first one was a cell viability assay
and this one is a more traditional assay
where you label cells with host
and then use propidium to identify dead
cells
because probing immidiate is not
normally
it cannot normally penetrate live cells
and so this was one assay and then the
other assay was the cell painting essay
where they set up their
um what they set up for of of the dyes
and then used this
in their high content experiment
and then generated not using cell
profiler but using perkin elements
columbus
1 300 features okay so now what i need
to do is
go through a little terminology that
they use in this paper
so they have a thing called the
benchmark response and the benchmark
response is the response that
essentially
creates a hit for a particular
measurement now
for the uh the
cell viability assay this was set around
three standard deviations from
from the negative control for the cell
profiler assay
this was set for plus or minus the one
standard deviation from the negative
control
now a benchmark concentration is for the
particular assay
and for a particular measurement that's
the concentration at which you get
a benchmark response and you'll see that
for example here
that is graphed here on the x-axis the
benchmark concentration
and then here the different measurements
so another key point here is that
the uh you know the measurement from the
particular assay that gives you
the lowest um benchmark concentration
is thought of as the the point of
departure
and then if we're looking at comparing
the two different assays
whichever assay gives the lowest um uh
point of departure is called the
the high throughput uh phenotypic
profiling
point of departure and that's the point
of departure for that particular
chemical
here are some examples the various
different
the various different channels that were
being used
and with compounds that give strong
phenotypes in those
particular channels and then here we see
some non-toxic compounds and then some
toxic compounds these are classic toxic
compounds
and the responses that they give this
it's hard to see here but this is
actually in
in increasing dose from here to here for
each of the compounds
and then these are all the 1300 features
for the cell painting assay
and then here are some responses in cell
count
and cytotoxicity
and then all the features are grouped
here according to the dna rna
the the the five different channels
okay now this explains how they group
the various different features in order
to come up
with the the the benchmark
concentrations and the point of
departure so this is a little bit
complicated but what you can see here is
here for berber and chloride these are
the responses
of all of the features and these are the
the benchmark concentrations so here you
can see
at this concentration you're getting for
this particular feature
a very high response and then here you
have features
that you're getting no response even at
high concentration so these are the ones
that are active
okay now what you do then is
you take all of these 1300 features
and you group them into 49 different
classes and so here you can see how
they're actually grouped so for example
you will have dna
intensity features dna texture features
dna morphology features
rna et cetera et cetera et cetera and
this builds up
into um and for the different
the different cellular compartments it
builds up into 49
different different
groups of features categories of
features
and then for each category you get an
aggregate score
for the actual uh benchmark response and
then
for each one you get a benchmark
concentration
and then the one that has the lowest
benchmark concentration that determines
uh the pod from the cell painting assay
and then
you can compare that with the results
from the uh
the cell viability assay and then come
up with your http
htpp pod point of departure
and so essentially this is what is
telling you is that what concentration
are you starting to get some sort of
effect from a chemical
either through the cell viability acid
or the cell painting assay
and then compounds that have a very low
point of departure
are things that you probably should be
worried about
as usual pre-incubation is an issue
and so you can see here that
with a lot of these
[Music]
with compounds you don't get any
response at three hours but then here
with this compound you start to receive
see a response in six hours 12 hours and
then it maxes out at 48 hours
so the general um
[Music]
protocol seems to be that it's a good
idea to pre-incubate again
for 12 hours the assay is
also
[Music]
very reproducible and so
here there are a number of different
plates where you're looking at
the various different responses the
the cell viability propidium iodide
response for stores born
you can see that they're very consistent
across all the different plates uh
the cell count from the cell viability
assay
again very consistent and here you can
see the responses
of the cell painting assay again across
all these plates so across from plate to
plate
it seems to be very uh very consistent
what was also interesting is that you
saw consistent responses
across different cell lines
which was which was also very
interesting
so if we think about the the tools that
you need to do some of this work
well as regards the image acquisition
you know all the
the the large instrument manufacturers
have
automated microscopes um and
there are also many smaller
manufacturers now who are
producing automated microscopes when it
comes to image analysis
um not every uh manufacturer especially
the small ones
have their own imagenous platform the
but the major ones do
uh the likes of sativa thermal
and molecular devices parking
perkinolymer etc
apart from the the commercial platforms
that come with those
instruments you can also use something
like image j or
cell profiler so cell profiler is a very
well established
open source image analysis platform and
that is
very suitable for a lot of this work as
regards image management
well again some of the commercial
platforms
have image databases and data management
databases that they
package with their instruments another
option for an open source uh image
analysis database
is the omero platform which is another
like cell profiler it's a very
successful open source
tool as well as the data analytics
for the processing of the numeric data
after you've done your feature
extraction
well when you look at these various
papers and you get excited about doing
that analysis often you'll find
that a lot of the work is done with you
know coding and things like or in python
and naturally you'll need you know
someone who can actually do that to help
you
replicate some of that work but you can
also do
things that are very similar to this
using some other
commercial and open source platforms for
example with our tool strataminer you
can
do phenotypic analysis and build machine
learning models
similarly in spot fire uh which is
marketed by perkin elmer for these uh
types of applications
cell profiler analyst also has some
machine learning and other analytical
tools built in
and then there is a pipelining tool nime
which is
it's kind of between you know coding and
r and tools like spot fire and strata
minor and allows you to build pipelines
using various modules
and do image analysis as regards
direct image classification some of this
type of functionality is built into
some of the image analysis tools such as
practice columbus where you could
identify cells and train models based on
those
also sativa have a tool called phenid
lifts that works with their encarta
these are based on machine learning
of the numeric features there are also
some deep learning tools out there which
we think will be very useful
for for some of this work
at the moment i think perk and elmer
have something for that and also
gene data have a uh a tool called
imogens
which is a deep learning classifier
there are also some other open source
things like advanced
cell classifier is a free tool um
that is also available
now if you look at this in a kind of
more general term uh
then you know the overall workflow is
taking this big data
doing advanced analysis using
computation
tools and then using data-driven
modeling
to kind of identify and classify these
various different events
from this kind of molecular initiating
event at the molecular level
then out to morphological events and
cells and then maybe
later on using more things like digital
pathology you could look at things in
tissues or organs and things like this
you know so that you can actually build
models possibly for each of these
different events and
try get a bigger picture of what's going
on and and how
and to be able to intervene to solve
these problems
as you're going along where can the high
content
analysis methods be useful well
definitely at the very earlier stages as
we've shown
they can be very useful of the discovery
process that can be very useful for the
predictive toxicology
later on also they can give you very
useful information when it comes to
working out
mechanisms of toxicity which could be
very useful for future programs and when
you look at the overall
impact of this kind of work yeah there's
a possibility that it could really have
when implemented at various stages and
using various different technologies
it could have an enormous impact on
your decision making as you as you are
working through
a an actual pipeline
so as to the future well one thing
that's very obvious
is that if you look at our high content
analysis we're looking at one particular
type of data there
um there's a lot of other types of data
that could be
generated from various other types of
analysis
various different omics technology
metabolomix perhaps
genomics rna-seq
very systems biology methods and i think
the future is how to
integrate these and pull them together
so that you can get a better bigger
picture
of what is going on in in
toxicology that you're seeing
so one thing you will notice is during
the presentation i didn't go into a lot
of details
about high content analysis itself
and a lot of the background and how to
do it and things like that
the reason for that is because this is
actually just one of a series
of webinars and a lot of that in
information
uh basic concepts on high throughput
screening and and
and uh high content analysis will be
dealt in some of these webinars that are
coming up
so there'll be one here by uh josh
harrell who was mentioned
during my presentation and also mark
anthony bray who was involved in
the development of cell painting uh
he'll be giving one and then later on
there'll be another one on
on 3d 3d models for drug discovery
so i would highly recommend that you get
on over
to the the lab roots website and
register for these ones because
together all of these will give you a
very nice package of
information on on high content analysis
for various different applications
and so finally i'd like to thank sbi 2
for the chance to
help out with this it's always extremely
enjoyable to work with sbi 2.
you should definitely check out the sbi
2 website and
have a look at the the annual meeting
hopefully next year that we'll be able
to do that
live again also i'd like to thank victor
wong at core life analytics
who was an enormous help in pulling
together all the information for this
and liz rubitsky who
was also very helpful liz works
in safety at drug safety at pfizer
and she was great help in in helping us
to figure out what we should be
presenting here
and uh liz should always also should
also be available
hopefully for to help out with some of
your answers to some of
the questions and so with that i'd like
to thank you all for joining and
we'll be taking some of your questions
thank you dave and thank you liz for
that outstanding presentation and we
will now
move to the live q a portion of our
webinar
as a reminder please submit your
questions in the q a
box so let's get started we have a
couple of questions
already here from our
wonderful audience our first question
is could people learning be useful
for toxicology
uh uh yeah i'll uh i'll take this one
um yes that's a very good question and
uh
unfortunately it's it's a topic that i
had hoped
to to cover but there was just so much
other cool stuff i thought maybe
we'll leave that for another uh for
another uh
webinar um deep learning of course is
you know very useful for image-based
screens
and you you know there are a number of
publications out there that have
uh that have used that another way to
use it is actually
not on the images themselves
but deep learning with the structures
and combining structural information and
uh calculated parameters from structures
with
uh uh previous talks uh data and so this
could be used to build models that then
could be applied
uh to uh new compounds so there was
actually a
i know in 2016 there was a um
an austrian group that built a tool
called deep talks
um and uh and that was uh
use that approach and of course there
are other they're actually now
commercial tools out there
uh also that are using deep learning for
images
i know uh perkin elmer has built
something for columbus
uh sativa have a thing called synap that
they recently launched
and and gene data as i mentioned the
talk gene data have
i thing called imogens so these are
things that people could uh
could possibly use one challenge with
deep learning of course is the amount of
data
that's required to build good models so
that is one challenge
for that wonderful thank you so much
david
our next question is what do you see as
the biggest
hurdle for applying this approach to 3d
co-cultural models specifically
spheroids
models
liz do you have any uh thoughts on this
one um
boy so we have uh an investigative talks
group that does
our uh 3d spheroids and
i believe that the the biggest hurdle is
just
consistent cell growth figuring out what
size spheroid you need
uh as far as the wet lab work
and as far as the data i think as
david mentioned before the sheer amount
of data
um is probably a hurdle um
david did you have any other thoughts as
far as the data analytics
um yeah i mean if so the
the uh the number of objects that you
want to acquire
that's going to impinge on the amount of
data that you have
um uh for let's say machine learning and
things like this
if you if you're just taking let's say
organoids as objects
and then but then of course when you
when you get to the volume of imaging
data if you're
doing z stacks uh that of course is
going to be a huge amount of data
so yeah that that would be a major
challenge as technically i guess one of
the biggest challenges
would be actually uh you know imaging
within you know uh 3d uh
structures and of course this isn't just
for talks but this is for any
any type of 3d structures uh if
you have larger structures can you image
uh deep into it to get uh
to get good quality data so um
yeah so i i think it's it's you know the
volume of data
and and then the standard kind of you
know how do you image in 3d structures
thank you so much to both of you and i
want to thank our audience again for
these great questions and remind them
that any questions that were submitted
and not answered today
will be answered via their email we have
time for one more question
how did how should one deal with
high autofluorescence in primary
hepatocyte sites
yeah so um we've run into
autofluorescence issues before and i
will say with the imager that we have
we are able to actually um do some
manipulation of the image
um which i know is a bit controversial
um but we are able to do that to um
get uh rid of the some of the
autofluorescence the other
thing that we do is we use a far red
dies as often as we can
so again it i think it mostly comes down
to your imager
and what options you have available
yeah that's a good one thank you so much
and i want to thank both of you for your
time today
i also want to provide you with a little
moment to provide some closing remarks
for our audience i'll start with you
david
yep so just in closing you know i
realize this is not a hugely
comprehensive
uh look at high content analysis for
talks i'm sure
there's lots more stuff out there but
the idea is to give people a taste of
what's possible
and you know at another time maybe we
can get into things like deep learning
uh one thing i would kind of reiterate
is please
uh have a look at the other talks
especially for those who you know
don't have a a big understanding of
a lot of the background of hca the other
some of the other talks will kind of
fill that in we just weren't able to get
them in the right order
be kind of because of scheduling
conflicts and so definitely josh
uh josh harrell and uh and uh mark
anthony bray's talks will be really cool
for filling in those gaps
and liz did you want to add anything um
just that um
i think that we're in a great point for
um starting to really see advances with
high content and toxicology um
it's just going to keep getting better
and it's an exciting time to be in it
the machines uh the technology and the
reagents that are coming out are great
i would highly recommend attending user
group meetings for the various companies
it's a great way to get to understand
the company and what's available
and and to meet other people and ask
questions there
i want to thank you both again for this
wonderful presentation
and i want to thank our audience members
and let them know that this presentation
will be available for on-demand viewing
in the sbi 2
virtual conference for 12 months so
please remember to share it with your
colleagues
who might be interested in today's topic
and do not miss out on the other
presentations on our agenda
thank you again for participating until
next time
stay safe stay healthy and take care bye
everyone thank you bye bye